he
w
[Music]
okay
h
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
w
hey what's up guys sorry for the delay
I'll blame it on blame it on me hi Rob
how you do oh don't say that it's all
good oh watch out there yeah we're good
so Eric how are you I'm doing all right
uh we got we're going to play some Zelda
today on a Thursday we awesome it's
awesome um and we're going to do some
early game Shenanigans not too many
story spoilers um and also Rob is going
to
field um either questions and or uh what
you guys want to see him do essentially
and he's going to try to do those things
why don't you why don't you explain a
little bit more yeah so uh you know
we've mentioned about this on uh the
lobby uh we're trying to start a or we
are starting a live uh weekly Zelda show
um where we kind of just take because
there's so much to do in Zelda like
physics wise and uh activities like
snowboarding and playing the game
differently in general we're kind of
just going to be doing that uh just kind
of you know messing around that was a
dumbass move just messing around with
the game really and um having fun with
it for instance we could do something
like play the game naked oh wow or just
in undies like us or him both oh okay I
I'll uh Stave off and not do that one
but you know sounds like a good idea but
yeah uh you know and a lot of this we're
kind of messing around with the idea and
uh I'm sorry it's really hard going back
to an early game and you have like
stamina like the second cuz you're like
what like 60 80 hours in now on your
like main save yeah and you start
realizing oh yeah I can't really climb
this wall that well like well don't jump
so much yeah exactly that's that's the
thing is with a rock climbing Set uh
there's a outfit that let you climb
really fast anyways yep um
so yeah if you have any like funny ideas
you put them in the chat and we'll kind
of incorporate them uh unfortunately I
didn't get I just realized now I I have
to get the parag glider and this last
thing so this actually kind of is a tad
story
spoilery okay um where it go rob I know
and I kind of messed that up but anyways
what I think we'll do is maybe me cut
away I can cut we'll cut away and we'll
just like get through it real quick and
and I'll you know I'll speed uh through
the cinematics
um you tell me when I will tell you
we'll go back to our somewhat beautiful
faces or more average looking faces I
don't know no I'm into that um yeah why
you just go ahead and just cut we won't
just in case anyone has not started uh
playing this game he's just on the in
the plateau right now but he is doing
kind of I don't know in a way
finishing uh the area so we're going to
cut away here for a second I'll even
bring the audio gameplay real low so you
guys don't hear anything neily but I
think a lot of it's just subtitle stuff
so hopefully he can get through this and
then we can uh continue he's going to do
some cool stuff um and or maybe we'll do
some crazy stuff by the end of the
stream yeah you know it's like every day
in the office you hear about people uh
just having different experiences like
you I mean you know again everything is
is such a spoiler like as far as your
experiences and stuff it is definitely
interesting because everyone like you
said does have different stories uh when
they play the game because there's kind
of so many ways to play or there's just
so much to explore and so much to check
out that you kind of get you know you
just wander off the beaten path
sometimes because you see something in
the distance or you see something that
you think might be like a cororo seed or
something and I just find myself always
just like going like oh man is that a
quox seed is that a quox seed
um and because of that stuff it's like
you know like you could just lose 30
minutes there and you're like oh [__]
right yeah and it's it's interesting
because I feel
like that could get really frustrating
and overwhelming yet it's just it just
kind of implies that how this world is
just so fantastic
uh and uh it's it's just mysterious in
every way right yeah like that's the
thing is you every every person you meet
everything you see you just wonder like
what is this what's the like outcome of
something uh and everything and that's
what's kind of mysterious you could
probably no I'll hold off we we we're
going to stay here just so that in case
anyone that hasn't I'm pretty sure most
people here have probably played at
least through this part but just in case
we won't spoil anything um also uh
shakalaka dingdong how long are they
streaming we're streaming about 90
minutes we did run a little late so
we're still technically got to end
around the same time because we have an
appointment after this so we'll be
ending around 12:00 so about an hour and
20 minutes give or take um a lot of
people talking about the the Wii U
version I didn't play that much of that
one uh I did watch Joey play a little
bit and it looked fine I played a little
bit totally fine I mean the game is not
texture heavy right like it's it's it
looks basically the same I would say uh
you know Tad Rough Around the Edges as
it is kind of like a cell shaded um type
game right uh however I didn't see any
frame rate stuff I heard I heard like
difference differences in like frame
rates for each of the two like
um that paraglider just about there uh
where like certain areas would uh have a
major frame rate drop for like one or
the other um it it's just kind of like
not I've seen like little smidget here
and there but nothing like oh my God
that's gamebreaking um and some people
are very like they're sticklers about
frame rate so like that would really
bother someone other like other people
are probably H you know like people that
played um Fallout 4 that game's just you
know you just not that you expect this
game to be Jank but like there is going
to be like you know there's that Jank
and you're like oh that's fine yeah uh
we're good you can come back now okay
good call uh I wanted someone gave you a
shout out so I gotta I got to read it
read it yeah I think it's conso hot
sorry if I butchered your name in
YouTube I took a nap dreamt about Rob
woke up and found him here that is
endearing and fantastic oh wait look
twitch finally decided to work I think
get out that was our uh big hicup this
morning was twitch was not uh
cooperating yeah but Eric we're back in
it yep let's do it give me some of that
hot gameplay on up oh yes yes you can
definitely have some of that my God I
love this game it's it's kind of funny
so I started a different save uh I just
kind of like the idea of just starting
all over again but then I don't no you
don't because then you you lose all that
stuff and you're like yeah so this is
good uh thanks for waiting everyone we
are we're doing it so we have one Tower
uh let's go somewhere so I think one of
the things we decided we're going to do
toward the end of the stream is we're
just gonna freaking book it for
Ganon oh yeah is that the end or we
doing this right now not right now okay
that'll be like towards the end we're
going to try to get to the the castle
essentially um with like very bare
minimum stuff almost Allah speedrunner
except none of us in the office have
spedrun at all so you know uh that'll
probably go great or poorly it'll go
really well uh yeah but for now I kind
I kind of just want to venture out into
the into the unknown like let's you know
let's go over here okay yeah yeah yeah
so I'm a big stamina guy I kind of like
stamina more than Hearts it okay so
that's that was a big one in the office
right like I took a heart first thinking
like oh I need more Health right but
like I feel like the next day after I
played I immediately regretted that
decision M and would have rather have
gotone stamina just because you use it
for so many things right like right I
want to say most most things that are
going to kill you at three hearts is
probably going to kill you at four
Hearts maybe not always sometimes you'll
end up with half a heart left but like
you know more often than not I feel like
having that extra Quarter Bar of stamina
like just watching you climb just now
that part I like it was very sketch
without that extra Quarter Bar so um
hello Teddy Lee welcome to the stream uh
on
YouTube and let's see oh yeah no no
clothes on oh you going naked naked we
going naked have you tried bare
fisting Oh I thought I timed it be bare
fisting yeah have you just used your
brass your nucks just my nucks just your
knuckles to to do some fighting oh yeah
eat that
skewer I mean I don't know what I can do
I I'm sorry I was trying to do brass see
this is already going real well yeah
yeah yeah I can
tell
wow that's one I should put a death
counter because you know
okay that was real bad I Can Do Better
someone I I miss I think console hot
also said they he he went through his um
you know his uh his phase with Fallout
so he if there's any hitches in here
they can handle it one gu is calling us
out because we're trying to convince
people about a crappy ass gaming system
um and accepting subpar frame rate
unbelievable I don't think that's the
case I'm just it's it's it's a reality
right like there is some frame rate
stuff in here it's going to happen but
it doesn't take away from like the
massive like exploration and just like
fun of this game I know it's it's kind
of weird to say because I
think I think that's like a very hard
thing to explain like you notice it and
then after a while I stop noticing it
mhm the I will say that it's very it's
where it gets frustrating is there when
it's foliage when it's like like intense
grass there's an area that I won spoil
that like um where it it's pretty bad
and you know Christ like it and it's of
course if you play uh handheld I have
never seen any frame drops like maybe
like once or twice but like nothing
compared to hooking it up to a TV or
something like that got um that's when I
you really see the drops but like
handheld it's it's interesting yeah cuz
it goes to 20 720p right yeah um Robin
summer in uh the Youtube chat asking how
is the audio music and breath of the
wild are there moments with music like
in the trailers or is it all
piano
um when you're roaming around it's
different types of piano and I think
it's it's meant to be not as noticeable
it's more like uh ingrained with like
what's going on you know like you you'll
hear the crescendo of like of keys when
you get into action and it's more of
just a a tell sign of like hey you're
about to get in some some uh some [__]
yeah but uh as far as like the good like
as far as music goes it's areas so it's
like you find a new area and generally
it's like its own soundtrack and they're
very very diverse oh what's this that's
that's the the little rupes bunny ah you
lost it damn no did I oh you know what
no that's a Coro no that little the
sparkly thing nah that's a Coro really
yeah
gotcha oh what I did not find that one
yeah there are different types of Coro
as far as like finding them like little
you know whether it's you know a little
puzzle with some stones or picking up a
rock picking up yeah picking up a rock
or uh there's kind there're these kind
of mini games where you like shoot
balloons and stuff yeah that one
frustrates me the most I'm just I guess
I'm just bad with bow and arrow I also
have to turn off cuz I've been playing a
lot uh on the tablet mode so like I got
to turn off that aim with the tablet cuz
I just happened to tilt it what's up
Josh shw welcome thanks for stopping by
our old buddy uh it's a cororo he says
yep my bad I I'm too used to seeing
those little um you know you know what
I'm talking about the little rupy
bunnies yeah I do yeah come here
uh-oh
ooh give him that hot uh witch time
witch time you got
it 360 oh there drops wow drop holy God
oh God okay uh I have not ever had that
bad honest to God I've never seen it
that bad that was real bad uh Jesus so I
guess if you try to MLG 360 uh scope
you're going to get some frame rate
droppage maybe yeah naked maybe it's
because I'm
naked ooh oh you think it's cuz you're
naked maybe I think it's cuz I'm
naked can't get me oh
[__] uh all right let's just try to do
this what are you doing ring his
butt he's sleeping oh oh oh you're there
maybe he didn't see you cuz you're
naked
oh let's
eat let's go with this mushroom
skewer see it what the f happened we
I've never had that happen to be honest
uh I don't know seriously I'm being real
honest yeah see Ryan King also on
YouTube that's the worst I've seen in 30
hours of playing the worst I've ever
seen it and that is I've played about 10
to 15 and that's the worst I've scene
and you know what that's pretty freaking
bad and I'm not going to lie uh that was
like after slow-mo we had some more
slow-mo pretty much um yeah I should
probably this
club oh man probably one of the only
major frustrating things is just the
inventory management for this thing like
yeah like it gets you I feel like you
have to very much be like so look at
this bat like it's it's got the arrow
I'll take you know what I mean like and
that's comparison to what I have on me
excuse me Sand's that yeah Sand's what
yeah yeah so I almost feel like you're
more inclined to um pick
up or I'm sorry always have like a
higher oh oh oh oh let's ride this do it
uh Josh saying you should be able to
drop a weapon when you pick up a new one
yeah I agree especially if it's better
but then it is tough because sometimes
you do have something equipped that you
like and it could be it it might be
slightly worse but you have worse in
your inventory right like you almost
always have something worse I feel in
your inventory that you'd rather get rid
of it's just not it's a little bit
cumbersome in that like you know you
have to go to your inventory menus find
what you don't want drop it then pick it
up um but yeah uh that was one of the
first things I upgraded I just dumped a
lot of my cor oxes into the like weapon
inventory slots cuz that seems to be the
way to go all right screw the deer here
even though I haven't ridden one of
those yet Ty Josh go get a horse that's
right let's get this horse
baby
all right which one you guys like here
who are you solid snake yeah taking
pictures of horses which horse do you
guys like in the chat please oh you got
to get that spotted one that blue one
the spotted ones aren't as fast as the
solid colors like this guy he looks good
okay you go get him okay narrate this
like it's a National
Geographic no I didn't mean to do
that get a little closer
here here we have a horse oh and now we
have these giant jellies look at them
glisten here's a weird one come here yo
do you ever feel like those eyeballs
remind you of like the game squat logo
oh my God you're absolutely right see
them I see those water guys yeah you're
totally right oh man so you know there's
different types of jelly you can drop
this um and
uh if there's fire jelly you can like
drop it and like lay it on fire and
stuff uh Ryan King does make a good
point though like it's easy to throw
your weapons to get you know pick up the
one you want but then bows and shields
are annoying so yeah pretty much yeah
here we go let's see here we go so the
thing is is that my stamina is a little
low yeah so you might not be able to he
might be a bucking
bronco ah you dirty you're a filthy man
what I'm just looking I'm looking I'm
looking for the M come here
oh wow oh wow that was quick that did
not take any it was meant to be it was
meant to be there was must not be a wild
horse look at this beautiful
horse yes yes let's go make it official
Let's Get
Married you're going to go to a stable
that's what I meant yes okay the chapel
if you will gotcha oh so always be
petting your horse yeah and feed it too
right yeah he uh so far the only thing
I've been able to feed a horse oh what's
this
uh oh I did not oh of course it's a a
chain it's not going to do anything
Robin uh summer with another question
are you excited for the DLC with hard
mode um how would you like this mode to
be oo that's a good question
so yeah what is the hard mode going to
be cuz it it better be something
significant right like if it's just
AI you know increased or like lower
Health like that' be weak I'm kind of
hoping for like a like a maybe like a
perade death like you know like wow well
Perma death in the sense that like you
can't save unless you're out of fire or
something like that I could see that
happening you know that's very
traditional
survival uh mode is like limiting like
how you and when you can save that could
be cool but it's kind of taking the easy
way out right like I I don't know what
else you could do um
currently just thinking about it all
right oops wrong move I we were talking
about earlier the buttons are so at
least you have here's a here's another
one we just cuz we're talking about all
this stuff and how to play Zelda
essentially sure I don't have a Pro
Controller and I'm pretty sure my
experience would be a lot better with
one but it's also $70 and there so
expensive uh I'm lucky enough to uh have
the office one that I'm using um I I
plan on getting one myself down the road
but once you go once you like feel how
the pro like just the joysticks in
general yeah operate with aiming God
it's it's significantly better um it's
tough like even like attaching like
handheld is is pretty good I'm I'm happy
with that but it's the other you know
when you put in the slot uh of the one
that comes with I don't know what it is
it's just the it's the Precision right
like you feel like you're constantly
like fighting the joystick uh cuz as you
know you you go up against like
Guardians right like that weak spot is
so small yeah uh crazy man 218 says dang
it I would totally go up to the first
enemy and fist fight it sounds like a
challenge to me Rob you can't fist fight
you can't all right let's
try well you okay so the monsters can
fist fight right like when they don't
have a weapon they usually like claw you
or tail whip you or something yeah cuz
you're right well you can try attacking
right like does it do anything just try
swinging why oh look at it's party oh
you're not even just going to attempt to
see if it does anything I can oh I'm
sorry I can I can do this that's pretty
threatening that's that's what happens
when you press y yeah I can do this oh
no that's that's cool uh there won't be
any fist fighting
then in the new hard mode the stamina
shouldn't regen wow I don't know about
that how are you going to kill these
guys with no with ingenuity
oh what's this what's this guys what H
do we have
here oh there weapons not you blue you
don't get
one
uh-oh my
axe o well let's see why you have an axe
yeah oh I dropped a shield ooh oh yeah
we like back flipping get out of here
where's your body old blue is confused
oh there he is he better be scared uh
the sensitivity on aiming is pretty
weird you're either on low and aiming
feels good but the camera feels so slow
or on high and aiming is super hard that
was from Ryan King from YouTube I
actually haven't Switched Off uh like
just whatever generic default is but I
definitely need to turn off that uh
stupid like tablet mode thing cuz it's
screwing me up as I'm trying to aim with
my thumb cuz I can't keep my hands still
I guess
yeah uh Dante Jackson heard the switch
isn't worth it but heard it that it was
still holding judgment I mean it really
ultimately comes down to if you think
you want to play Zelda or you're going
to play Zelda if you or and or if you
have a Wii U actually because I guess if
you had a Wii U you could just play
Zelda on the Wii U and not buy a switch
but if you want to play Zelda on the go
then you want to switch I don't know I
just came up with multiple scenarios
like and that didn't make any sense
i i i the handheld no you're I mean
handheld
uhoh bees at
bees oh you know it would be really
tasty with chicken honey glaze chicken
oh yeah that's I thought you could do it
with uh choo choo jelly Choo Cho but I
was wrong uh let's get that
honey and I'mma
throw uh uh this
this uh Dante also says you know like
part of his struggle too is cuz he's not
a big Nintendo fan um I I can say the
same thing though Dante I've never been
a huge Nintendo fan other than N64 I
mean I didn't so I didn't have a snz
right I had a Genesis so it's was like
usually most families have one or the
other so I don't I only ever played snz
at my cousin's house which is very
little um but I had an N64 because of
Mario Mario 64 and I was at my friend's
house I was like oh God okay I have to
have one you know and then when you guys
had the switch I don't know was it like
a week early for like review and stuff
like that the more you guys just kept
talking about Zelda and watching you
guys play it was the stream Peter and I
did I feel like that I remember like
hearing you you came in the room after
you were like I think I'm going to go
get one yeah and I was just like all
right so then on on that Friday cuz I
knew Target was going to like you know
every like it was reported that they
were going to have some right like in
store I was like all right if I go and
they have it like and it was meant to be
then I'll buy it you know and then I
ultimately buy bought it and I I like
the game a lot I think there like I have
like minor frustrations but that's just
like me getting used to like the kind of
game and stuff like that mhm stamina and
whatnot
um and just like some of the puzzles
like uh in shrines annoy me personally
like how the mechanics of like what they
want you to do like like they're they're
difficult or they're they're big uh it
was not so much difficult as it was
annoying so like do you think it's a
spoiler just talking about the
mechanic I'll just say this I had to use
my tablet to like Spin and rotate
something and it was like super
frustrating to like I'm like come on
just line up please this is so stupid
like I have no you know like I can't
precisely aim this thing and it's like
driving me mad you know and it's funny
to like go in the menu and turn off the
motion controls and you still have to do
it so I tried I tried like I actually
tried like undocking it I put the
kickstand up I tried using just the
controllers and it's so much slower I
don't know why and like I was like this
isn't working and then luckily Matt ESP
panelli was like have you tried like
flipping it backwards I was like I
didn't even think about that whoa but
like why like why would you know I
should be able to do it like straight up
but anyways there's yeah exactly as Josh
said couple horrible motion control ones
you know and of the of the ones that
I've heard people talk about I've done
those I think maybe that's like two to
three maybe four MH uh of the probably I
don't know I've probably done like 40 of
those things yeah I I haven't seen one
in a while okay as far as motion um yeah
you're doing like the control like
you're turning it and you're trying to
line it up and then like as you're
lining it up you're like oh [__] but I
have to press B right now to like make
it stop you know yeah and uh so Josh
when I meant flip it backwards I didn't
actually mean flip the the switch
backwards I mean like I rotated at 180
so that like the top was the bottom and
the bottom was the top or whatever right
um I'd rather like I like the ones where
you know you have to think about like
how does this work you know like what am
I supposed to do to do that you know do
I need to turn this thing off how do I
you know like that stuff's cool to me
but those ones are just like that that
one really bothered me yeah yeah I mean
in in the grand scheme of things like
it's it's m
yeah like you get through it um so I
just realized I am I'm broke I'm I'm
naked link with no money so let's sell
some stuff to this yeah yeah this guy's
nose is so weird is it though and then I
like how is it though I'm sorry you've
seen this before I have I have and then
I like how he has a little flag of
himself too in case you didn't see him
hey guys you know I never noticed that
and it's also a a frowny face flag like
what like uh Ryan King asking have you
been taming multiple horses it seems
like you only need one horse and I feel
guilty letting all those sexy horses
pass me by um so
the like what what's the horse it's like
an like a all black horse with like a
black man um those guys yeah he is
awesome he is very like timid and uh low
tempered but he's like the fastest horse
um yeah so I would say that one you can
yeah you can have as many horses you
really want uh I'm going to sell him
this crap food okay for uh Weapon X
gaming asking why is he shirtless with
[__] we're just uh doing early game
Shenanigans trying to see what life's
like um
naked you know all that's enough uh I'm
sorry yeah yeah yeah life is different
when you are wearing briefs and it's God
it's chilly out right it's got some
sweet boxers though man yeah I do like
those uh anyways get back to horses like
so I have um like one of the first
horses horses I had was like really
strong like mhm I would say that you
want a couple maybe uh you'd have a
stronger horse to ride into battle
against a guardian and then one to like
get around quicker right like okay uh
the timid horse I had he like freaked
out against a guardian threw me off and
like just left me stranded and did not
go
well the interesting thing for me is
I've only ever really had one horse that
I felt like I had a strong bomb with and
and I was in this area where I was like
man I have no idea where the closest
stable is I'm so sorry buddy I got to I
got to let you go Goodbye Oh what should
we name him Eric I don't know that's a
good
question can horses die in this game I
would believe so right cuz Peter said
you can kill dog too right you I have
not killed a dog cuz I'm not that cold
but I'm not the Monster uh I let one of
my horses di once and it was really sad
and his name was Charlie I had my first
dog was named Charlie hey how do we how
how about we do this in the chat people
in the chat give me one letter randomly
oh God and I'm going to take the first
lineup of like five letters and make it
all right there's delay so I'll let that
come in um just going to read a YouTube
comment uh from Nikki C4 saying Nintendo
Japan reports that survival DLC your
health drops over time and you have to
eat to
live and I'm not going to read that back
part because that's
mean d
Charlie too no no no you better put the
letters in I want some vowels Steve
Brule name him Steve Rule no I did I say
letter or word here we go l c l d a
l da a thank you Nikki c24 though for
the first half oh you just named it no
no I just got again oh here they come d
l what was it scroll back up uh d a l
KT d s DL K was it yeah
KT
D and then s h t I need a vow no you got
to take the chat letters H it's h and
then T and then n uh what's delete I'm
still going to use no it's B godamn it h
t another t wait yeah it was yeah yeah
yeah it's a t the next letter is a t i
and then
MK yeah it's fine
do MK MK no that's enough I don't want
to go much further oh you can only have
one more letter so M okay fine we'll
leave it with that do sheet I can have
one more letter all right let's do it do
she do doy for short okay uh thank you
guys for getting in there thanks for
thanks guys this name looks great wow
the letters are coming in real hot now
way to goow Rob all right the next horse
we'll do it again we'll try to name it
Pete Brown we should have named it Pete
Brown oh next one next I like this name
I like it I like it thank you everybody
thank you everyone F you that's good
name H yeah YouTube name is a horse
that's
correct thanks to whoever brought the
a he totally looks like dokey doy dokey
you want an apple
apple
apple I thought I saw an apple around
here thought you didn't pick any
up Apple treay where's the Apple so
thank you guys again for uh those tuning
in on YouTube and twitch and Facebook
and Gamespot uh we appreciate you guys
hanging out with me and Rob doing some
Zelda early game Shenanigans um you know
if you haven't already lik subscribed
and all that stuff you know do that so
that we can keep doing more live streams
and content and and stuff like that I
know that um Rob and Peter are going to
start hopefully next week because
Peter's just stuck in jury duty um he is
in jury duty uh you guys are going to
start doing some Zelda on Thursdays
right every Thursday 10:30 we'll be
streaming um this is kind of a taste of
what we'll be doing today was a nice way
to have a teaser a little light we were
uh kind of just I kind of want to come
in today just kind of experiment with
like the idea of messing around like
this um but the plan is to have more
like actual oh my
God
[Music]
up uh the plan was to you know fight one
of those mess
around I mean I'll lose I have I have
absolutely nothing against this guy yeah
I don't even know okay
so someone said that you could Parry the
laser and one shot him but I don't know
if your Shield will yeah with like a
like a a a metal shield or a night
all right let's uh I don't know if
chat's
up your boy Josh get
him all right let's see what happens you
got this man do I yeah cuz if you nail
this if you nail this one we might as
well end the stream right no arrows all
right perfect oh man how much time do we
have we got a lot of time we got well we
got like a good 50 minutes to we could
go slightly over I think the
appointment's at 12:15
uh gaming gumper says Nope works with
any Shield I
guess doy it's been real unless there's
miscommunication in terms of like if you
can reflect his laser with a regular
shield oh these guys oh these guys are
going to be annoying without arrows all
right well I have to take or maybe you
have the guardian kill them no no
they're they're all buddies well what if
the guardian's aiming for you there's
there's no Friendly
Fire I've never tried it so I'm just
just trying to think like that you're
telling me to like lur them into the
laser of the Guardian yes with with
dokey all right no oh a these guys are
real jerks I know what what did one of
them have a magic wand what the hell was
that green stuff what the hell oh he's
got oh he's probably got I think he's
got uh guard Guardian uh arrows ancient
arrows I don't know you tell me um oh I
can't do this I'm not going to Nikki see
for is dropping some more knowledge oh
oh hello
lightning yeah lightning uh dropping
some knowledge in the chat which is cool
uh I don't want to read it out loud
because
spoilers what uh I'll try to highlight
it for you this one right
here can you see that the dungeon
Souls well that's he's no that's not
okay then he's making stuff up he's I
think he's being funny like it that's
why you're here I'm a I'm a 10-hour
novice and you're a 60h hour
Pro I will tell you this much I do go
pro HUD oh wow okay it's so busy I don't
need all that stuff look at all that
clutter you know well you're used to it
right so it's way it's a fun way to play
though keep it clean yeah look for the
stream show me those hearts and the
Spurs oh we got some rips I like it we
should like uh rips rest in peace rip oh
when I died I should uh I should have
like a RP
counter come here you [__] come here
you and your short range
sword and he's got his big Boo bat
trying to hit a home run it's a joust
this guy has no idea he cannot control
his swing come here I don't know man
he's got more uh radius on his attack
than you do Mohammad says kill the
guardian we're going to try I think he's
try trying to get rid of this horse
first and foremost or this uh boblin I
love these guys uh ad kinus 85 we are
also on Twitch twitch.tv/ Gamespot but
you know you guys watch wherever you
want um and thank you guys for tuning in
batter
up how do you like that big boy oh boom
shakalaka go go gadg man saying no HUD
is the way to
go not even not even a stamina says guci
right no they're stamina bar stamina bar
you can't get rid of that uh but that's
actually like At first I was like oh I
wish I could get rid of it but you need
it there is value guardian and five
tries dude I can't kill where was that
other guy with the arrows I want him I
don't know man I'm going to get rocked
so hard why would you why would you
doubt
yourself cuz I just know oh here's my
guy oh yeah is he a blue goblin too yeah
the last guy the last guy was not uhoh
no he doesn't uhoh uhoh uhoh uhoh oh wow
good thing he sucks at
aiming or maybe you gave him the old you
know oh you oh wow come here making me
real
nervous oh you're still
good I don't know how but you're still
good uh dark lord decision says sneak
past the Guardians and into hyru Castle
we'll do that at the end we're going to
try uh with his limited
resources um but yeah that is that is
the goal for the end of the stream um
and we'll see if we get to that oh come
here come here yeah yeah get off your
horse oh
great he's trying to get back on his
horse crap well what am I doing you do
you did I just throw no you threw your
boab
ax I love the skeletons though like
great they just keep chasing like around
looking for a
body oh
you're oh what a jerk playing soccer huh
oh a great look at me having fun should
have just killed him where's that
goddamn get the bow Beetle get him oh
heet hey Beetle hey
run look at his little pose his wind
pose
yeah dang it uh dark lord also saying
Shield surfing is also fun on these
Hills past the
Guardians dude Shield surfing uh Rob
does Shred the Nar sometimes dude it's
it's tough I've mastered it I'm going to
make a guide later check it out Gamespot
another rest in peace
GG uh yeah you know it h things happen
don't go in a tar man no tar pit maybe I
can get my horse in there
oh no Calla call
uhoh uh Tyler and Josh you'll die if you
go after Ganon pretty much guaranteed
yeah well we'll see that's part of the
reason why we're going to go after him
oh yeah just a little swag jump that was
a real bad move let's see how this pans
out you don't have any arrows right
that's right I keep
forgetting I I just kind of
did
I all right I I can't go against those
guys yes you can you killed
yourself all right one more time one
more time it one more time agree
disagree [__] Beetle got wrecked says
whiz big tactics he's all right I think
he's all right he got shocked a little
bit you know just a little little shock
therapy I like I don't know what to do
that's why I killed myself cuz that was
the only thing I could think of doing
that's true that would make it easier
all right come here come here at least
kill this guy yeah I really want this
guy done and his arrows I want those all
right I want
that bad show them who the real don't
don't do it oh dang it not my
horse not
dokey are you going to eat two of those
yeah dang oh wow he's
just oh no he ran into God damn
it nice jump oh yeah I have a uh [__]
actually this will
work oh yeah scared him
sorry what am I doing I don't know what
you're doing I'm trying to get my stuff
out I'm panicking where you going
yeah all right
uh aim for the
legs oh
man uh thank you Jeff Schult see you
later uh this isn't too far in the game
for those uh other people watching if
you're curious oh you know what I do for
those guys I just drop a
bomba
you know what I mean like you leave
behind a
oh this guy's a lot strong yeah well he
is a blue b
coblin get out of here bird Birds bats
they're bats they're oneeyed
bats yeah this guy never knew what uh
hit him don't should use your oh
actually you do you ever
oh crap
and just using everything sweep the leg
says Roland Greco we're trying to sweep
the leg this guy's leg is too
strong got him oh nope not yet oh yeah
oh baby big daddy wants
some dude the laser didn't even hit me
it it like the the the minuscule amount
of heat from the laser fried me
instantly I well you are naked right all
right you are naked I am naked that's
true it's only 11:20 we got so much time
man uh I gotta get past this guy
Invincible saying 5 days spend 45 hours
sounds about
right let's get out of here what all
right so you lost to the blue boin this
stream the stream cannot entail me just
getting wrecked by a guardian we're just
for the fun sakes because I got a second
I'm going to go ahead and oh that would
cool and uh get us ourselves
a Rest In Pieces do this there we
go come here bats so I think Bob Bob
said five deaths right now I feel like
there's been more than that though this
is more appropriate a bat for the
bats batter up
oh ah
so like I lure those guys like I let
them chase me and then I put a a bomb
behind me yes and then they like all
blow up that's a pretty good tactic I
like that all right we got a we got
ourselves a good oldfashioned death
counter now and I'll update that as Rob
continues to die because I feel like
it's going to happen I'm not going to
die anymore a few more times you know uh
I'm not gonna die anymore yeah I you I
was thinking about it yeah not gonna die
anymore yeah I'm kind of over that
ooh what's this this is called
distraction ooh it's a well what's in it
nothing okay let's go oh that's not
always necessarily true though right
like sometimes there's catch oh there's
a weapon there's a rusted sword over
there though is there maybe if you throw
that in
there
nope uhoh oh you know I don't do that
enough I feel
like
be funny if you could actually like put
that
on wear it that would be awesome
[Music]
nope see I told you I wasn't going to
die anymore
ooh supposedly have you heard this you
throw you could throw a rusted weapon
into a octo rock those like guys who
spit oh yeah yeah yeah crap the yeah
yeah supposedly if you if you throw it
uh into them they'll back out a clean
sword really yeah like they'll take off
the rest want to try it let's see if we
can find a guy fine let's do it I don't
think they're here though right in this
generally in water earlier area I feel
like I didn't see them until I got
closer to the next place but maybe that
was just me I feel like they're
generally around in water a what's going
on there
hey yeah I'm I'm coming you got to help
you got to help I'm coming
hey mister pick on some of your own
size
uh-oh oh they can't swim they sure can't
Eric they cannot swim all right reward
you get nothing oh wait no you do get
something look at I love Link's action
pose just like yeah have no fear ooh oh
I didn't get that I got something else
sneaky veggie rice balls that's my my
fa uh wow Miss thanks dark lord does
confirmed the Octo rocks uh
do I'm guessing that's refresh rusted
weapons thanks Leica
bye-bye hey man at least she gave you
some food she sure did I'm hungry let's
eat I always like to eat after a nice
battle hi hi there kind sir my name's
link skull Lake that's where I go for my
vac okay thanks Hulk saying there's so
much hidden stuff in this game yeah
there's a lot of just different
mechanics just different stuff to
explore different like like we had
mentioned earlier every day I feel like
everyone has a different story or like a
different moment and then some people
have that same moment and some don't and
they're just like oh man how'd you do
that that's like part of the the
excitement of this game I think yeah
we've said this so many times but yeah
that was like the first few hours we're
like wait what like like right after the
tut tutorial I was like wait you did
what like H how did you see that I was
like well I went through the mountains
like oh I went underneath them or to the
side of
them good tip is that guy's named snooze
oh I didn't see it I was trying to look
at the the chat so like just even this
area I really haven't gone around here
oh look at this crap head piece of
garbage got spotted uh horsey just the
butt
whoops yeah pin
him man I'm I'm really into the unknown
here look at
that crazy way somewhere though the tow
right there
too yeah I could probably get it it's a
Jou he wants that's a Jou he'll
get game
on suck it oh that was
anti-climatic what I thought that was
pretty neat uhoh oh know I think it was
I thought what you she did was pretty
cool but the way he just died was just
like oh okay I told you I wasn't going
to die anymore we'll see about that
let's get rid of these
things that's right you can throw them
that's a good point I keep forgetting
about that that was a good tip some of
said
chat yeah it definitely works for the
weapons but uh harder for the um shield
and bow yeah oh look this guy he's like
you killed my brother doy yep samor we
know that uh we can deflect um Guardian
lasers with the Parry which is not
necessarily taught to you from the
beginning you kind of just have to
experience it or I think there is a
training area at some point same with um
doing the like Dodge which gives you
almost pseudo ban at a witch time uh and
you get a bunch of free attacks if you
perfect Dodge essentially yeah it's the
timing of that is insane it's easier on
like the bo goblins once you get used to
them yeah especially that jumping attack
that like really far jumping attack that
one's like probably the easiest one yeah
totally um yeah the bigger guys it's
it's you can't do it cuz that's the
thing is you you know you you want to do
the uh The
Hop um Fury is it called Fury or flurry
flurry flurry flurry
attack oh sorry dokey get out of here
you have no weapon
thanks what and you got some skellies
now or a
Skelly you know what I do with these
guys sometimes this is a good tactic see
look it want sorry interrupt you see
look it I got the arrow on it oh wait
hold on two arrows guess what thanks
butt head
Nice Shot
thanks ah you farm him a different way
so what I let him do is I just run
around and let them Miss and then I just
go pick up the arrows but I guess it's
more efficient to just block it but that
takes away from Shield durability right
I'm assuming or not really it probably
does okay uh I don't know uh yeah I do
that too uh there's actually a limit to
how many shoot well no he'll he'll
always keep shooting but um there's a
limit to how many will be left gotcha uh
gaming gumper says how did you collect
those he you basically just blocked and
then just like sto blocking right and
then those one I uh whipped out the
shield and then I'm like
thanks I you know what I tried because I
thought it would totally work when I
first blocked an arrow I was like oh I
got an arrow stuck in my shield I'll
just drop my shield and pick it up and
I'll get both and then I was like nope
didn't get both thought I was smart but
I wasn't sh shut
up they're
sleeping I don't want to wake him
but I do want to kill them just remember
that the the blue Goblin's probably in
there and you that [__] sneak attack oh
that's the worst way to
die sneak attack sweet dreams oh there's
one guy on post he hasn't fallen asleep
yet o I got an
idea uh question do you ever increase
your inventory spots is that a spoiler
um I kind of already said it so I guess
oh he was like no dude game on but yeah
you you can
I mean I don't think that's too much of
a spoiler not too much spoiler yeah
those those we won't say how necessarily
but yeah oh yeah I guess you can go
ahead and say they just kicked they just
kicked it and then
like okay I got an idea this is going to
be super hot oh no oh it's morning oh
look at them they're like yeah it's
another day being a [__] really what
you don't see is they're listening to
EDM w w
boblin
EDM damn it oh God
uhoh thought you weren't going to die
anymore
man what a liar he just stabbed you
right in the back damn it with his
uh oh dang it I did not think that this
white see I gave be ban the doubt in the
game won't even let me keep the rip
counter because it goes to
White it's personal now doy Li James
says take a selfie with that sleeping B
coblin ah
[__] oh all right that dumb loin cloth
yeah they get wear beef wear briefs dude
they do get a little bit smarter too
like as you go oh they definitely do
yeah they'll they'll kick things away or
like throw them away they'll pick stuff
up and throw it at you like I've had a
guy pick up one of those exploding
things and throw it at me the moblins
are the bigger ones bigger ones they'll
like if he is far away and you're you
know dealing with babins right in front
he'll pick up a bobblin if it's near him
and he'll throw the bobblin at you and
then the bobblin will like either hit
you but regardless he'll like get up and
start fighting it's like freaking
hilarious gaming gumper says you can
also use these uh metal canisters as a
ramming object uh oh
duh oh you're going to go stasis on
it oh man are we going to get to see
what happens it
though did it do anything it didn't do
anything because I didn't do it right a
Christ uh it's all good it is all good
come
closer
see what's this
box oh look he's running away let me go
chase him
we're just messing around uh reedo
Fiesta that's why we're not using any
armor
oh throwing big bigger objects oh he got
his budy see so what an
idiot o o yeah going to lose your travel
Shield soon oh yeah you want to go uhoh
D that does like oh yeah these guys are
blue
God all right all right all right all
right so oh just wanted to show everyone
how to die yeah all right can you get
good yet dude [__] I can't you want me
to turn it on I've been playing upside
down I just pulled the wrong box you've
been playing upside down really secretly
yeah okay let's wreck these guys move it
down here I guess let's do
this nope didn't mean to do
that have to pay
respects uh oh
man no no nope this is not going well
it's going
great it's perfect just how I want to do
it yeah I know right everyone else
asleep come on Jesus God you love that
jump attack too much I feel like I do
love it too
much was the bomb meant to be a
distraction oh no oh I I didn't know it
rolled crap blew it like you do realize
that it like rolled away oh no dokey
somehow he went on fire and then became
not on fire he's fine oh we got a death
count it's it's down
[Music]
there see him oh
B
Tyler and Josh y'all probably should get
armor or this will be never ending death
of blue Bo by Blue boblins
never n he'll be fine it's not oh yeah
oh yeah you want to go
dude oh sorry dude you're just
destroying
dokey please shout me out what's up
Andrew Brett suck Hammer oh this guy's
dancing he's like yeah I'm
a blown
come over
here yeah yeah come closer oh no you
just woke up a cave of them uhoh I think
that's three bin blue bow goblins yep
they don't see me ah My Feet my foot
sees ooh that
hurt uh I got some meals here oh I
should have used this and snuck in that
base
whatever gaming gumper no HUD is the
best way to play at least when I can
tear it away from my son is what I think
me to right uh that's why you need two
switches I
guess rip them
boxers what's no idea right to me oh no
I screwed that up where you going I
don't know it's it's weird it's like
they're going to maybe light their
weapons on fire is probably what it is
yeah cuz they figured out that works
pretty well I'll do this drop them boxes
on them what Josh says oh you
dead oh you gonna wall him
off get yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
magic oh my God no it was totally
intentional I was not going to hit
myself suck it oh my head Dam it didn't
do any damage he's like what's going on
he no he is he's he's like delusional
he's unconscious this guy's a big dumb
dooy as you would
say oh oh he's got Ries no the Box did
oh okay I was about to
say ooh Bass little base little boss
right in
hist my name's link I don't need
clothes that's what he says sounds about
right he says that all the time that's
what he would sound like oh oh the
shield of the Mind's Eye better equipped
it it's pretty good I never got anything
that good this early I feel like when I
was playing
some if you whip them around they do
damage yeah he's just doing o trying to
Drop It Like It's Hot essentially
hello let's get another one of these oh
oh he's
fast oh my God he's fast this is like I
wonder if like that border is like where
they like stop chasing you or something
cuz the other guy just like why this is
like the dumbest I've ever seen these
guys oh I need something
right
and he's
dead all right we should probably move
on uh yeah or should I kill
these Che K all these dudes welcome to
the stream uh you do you man kind of
want that oh there's two all right we
got to do
it let's always do it for the treasure
man let's do it oh yeah I got one too oh
my
horse
done you got no arrows I know I keep
forgetting
yeah if there's anything
else
uh minor that you guys want to try to
see or whatever or questions keep asking
them YouTube twitch Facebook Etc we'll
do our best to answer them oh oh Jee
jeez swing it
around get ramming speed oh let's do
this you think he'll be dumb enough to
stay there yep
too high
though oh he's
eating
oh man the guy was just trying to
eat I don't know why these guys are so
dumb uh like they're not you know what
is dumb cuz you're naked they're like oh
shoot that's a hot that's a hot looking
man right
there uh what's up the Draco 7 oh
actually those I'll just say what's up
to you anyways he says use a fire weapon
but uh dry cone 30 welcome to the stream
I don't use a fire weapon
well fine you can light it on fire oh I
know what to do oh I know what to do all
you ready for this I am my body's ready
awesome and
[Music]
then I love your
party
all right how you going to deal with
this
guy he'll never see it coming
Rob someone order a hammer oh what
what oh I know I'll do oh dude I know
what I'll do watch this what are you
doing oh no wait I can't hold it oh cuz
it's a dish that's
why Mind Games Eric B switch you hungry
hungry oh what's that
Oh Sees you though eat it no he sees you
though I think
right yeah yeah like let me get a stone
here well that was pretty easy yeah
Spike boo clubs are pretty good in the
beginning here yeah definitely all right
Next plan of action let's cook cuz I
need some of that food do you though you
don't think I do not really
okay see the problem with blowing these
up with bombs is like it launches the
stuff all the
stuff
great Apple oh I'm going to give one to
dokey where is dokey what's dokey what's
doy's full name again dokan doy dokan
[__] or something like that right
something like that I don't
know I'll save one for
him just getting a nice little sear on
it yeah so you can bake you can get like
a yeah you pull a little bit more right
yeah you got to pull them quick though
or else they'll
explode hey dokey saw sorry about that
earlier uh part where you got hit with a
boulder and stuff eat uh hi Le asking if
I buy breath of the Wild on my Wii U
will I be able to plan on my switch in
the future I don't think that's how that
works unless I'm crazy I don't think do
they have some type of like
compatibility thing I guess we'd have to
look that up I haven't heard anything
about could you can you can digital
download it oh look at this he's
hunting yeah what up I'd have to look
that one up for you I don't think my
logic would say no but you never know I
mean if they're a good guy Nintendo they
would totally well what if you did a
digital download for Wii U would that be
oh oh wow he killed it for you oh no you
just what no I spanked him with your
sword damn
it doy's going to go Rogue on you like
shadow of
wardor how big is the map the map's
pretty big uh fulfill lad it's it's
freaking huge and it's dense dense oh
look at all those
apps see this is what I meant by getting
distracted you should just chop it you
should just chop the tree down can I
yeah with a wood cutter or with what you
have now but n it's the best
oh Eric you are a smart man I've never
done that I was like f climbing this
tree to grab all these apples I'm just
going to dude I've I didn't even think
about that just going to chop this tree
down especially when there's that many
ain't got time got be picking apples I
just cut the damn tree down all right
let's Venture forth here's what here's
what we're going to do we got 20 minutes
is oh do we yeah should we do it plan
yeah should we do the do we got to do it
all right let's do it we're going to try
to sneak into Hyrule Castle at the very
least let's sneak around see what's up
okay uh I hear there's tons of fun
things to do with Ganon and his friends
okay so we'll see if uh oh wait which
way do I
go I don't know you know better than
me it's so funny thinking this link
with you think about how many like
universes there are link and then this
universe link is so dumb he just like
gets on a horse with no armor he's just
like he's like I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go get
Canon all that let's go get
Canon let's
[__] uh anyways distraction uh holly wolf
says thanks for the highlight of my
Zelda cosplay on your Facebook thanks
for uh sharing it say what what was that
uh I guess there was we did like a Zelda
cosplay thing on Facebook think maybe
someone in chat um saw it
and that's cool mhm hot link link oh
look that guy some some Link Cosplay
where do I how do I get in here sneak
right into the Guardians says Steve
Esser question mark yeah right into the
Guardians yeah let's go get Canon just
fight the final boss uh my name is link
let's go get Canon I don't even think
we'll get to him but we'll try I'm ready
I'm ready to update this rip counter
though I'm ready I think he's going to
get to double digits before the end of
the
stream oh what am I at right now what's
up fire bucket I at right now you're at
7 uh that's Rob right there I'm Eric
thank you guys for thanks for joining us
joining us uh yeah so again we're we're
going to be streaming uh Zelda every
Thursday at 10:30 a.m. Pacific uh the
plan is to you know this is this is kind
of a testing grounds of just like is it
enjoyable to just mess around so far I
think I'm having fun because I'm playing
Zelda I don't know what you guys but uh
next week we'll uh I'll be joined with
Peter and we'll be uh having will have
more goals and it'll be more of an
interesting yeah there'll be more
focused streams I believe like there
might be one on like just snowboarding
or like extreme sports as we'd like to
call them right uh there are a lot of
things you can do with octo Rock
balloons oh yeah they float stuff right
or make them aerial and we would
basically spend essentially the plan for
the stream and you know if you guys have
any ideas as well as during the stream
we'll we'll take ideas but the plan is
to uh you know have two to three
activities planned and limitations for
instance like this wearing no clothes
and then uh every every episode or every
stream will end with uh this trying to
go and Tackle Ganon who knows maybe down
the road we'll actually do it yeah
actually that could be like the final
one or something we'll see how it goes
but yeah if you guys are interested in
that at all you know just follow like
subscribe all that good stuff and um
we'll have Triforce uh I keep calling it
Triforce Thursdays just because it makes
sense but um yeah Peter and Rob will be
back
um you know we'll update that that death
counter because Rob's a filthy liar and
said he wasn't going to die again and
he's died like three times since I never
I never said that no you did uh you want
me to pull it up on the archive that's
cool uh so I really don't know where I
last saved this sucks what's up Alex ya
there's your shout out thanks for
tuning oh
perfect leave her
alone headphone Mage says you can call
uh you can do a series called horing
around Hyrule the name actually we have
right now is the
Triforce yeah the Triforce TR y Force
Peter thought of that Peter yeah
brilliant you better you better hustle
man oh am I am I losing time here I mean
if you're trying to do what you want to
do I don't know how many times I mean
I'll do it all right I'll just kill him
I'll just kill genon let's just do
it hi my name's think we're going to go
right for
Canon oh
sorry I've never so far I've never gone
this
far yeah you're right it's kind of far
away all right so the thing we have to
look out for it looks close but it's not
that close the thing we we have to look
out for our
Guardians that's right Josh nailed it
Triforce this is pretty nice A little
peaceful oh
birs
Zelda I'm
coming are you though I'm coming all
right horing around Hyrule would just
focus on horses got it oh okay
uhoh it begins it's actually pretty fun
to just use the dash move on um on
enemies because you can actually hurt
them you got this you got
this you just oh ah nope nope nope dokey
not
now oh donkey took the hit for you what
a stud he is a stud oh my God he's like
no no I don't want I don't like this
laser you're going to give me PTSD from
these Guardians so far it's going
swimmingly better eat this
Appo all right let's try
again excuse me have you seen
Zelda hi have you seen
Zelda yep you
no if you guys have ideas of what you
like to see uh you know hit up Rob on
Twitter at Robert Handlery um or Peter
Brown at PC Brown uh they're going to
try a bunch of fun cool stuff uh this
could have been one of them uh that he's
showing you right now while he's uh you
know squirms his way you know what to
the castle you what's up I think it's
about time to have some of these a
sneaky F
RBS you think you're going to be that
much more sneaky when you're Stark naked
you you know okay maybe the let the wind
brush off my smooth skin and right past
me no one
was my name is link and I'm here for
Zelda no one will know I am coming
in here I come so slowly SOA I'm coming
but steady how's the fox get in here
he's just hanging out man that's the one
animal I really hate killing look at
that cute little boy all right what did
the fox say though I just realized I
left dokey goodbye dokey he'll be fine
he'll be kind of where you're
at damn look at this
pillar uh Josh mentioning does anyone
else find the hearts hard to see or is
that him just being slightly colorblind
has hard to see yeah hard hard to see
but you'd have to ask somebody that
suffers from color blindness Josh's
color BL I guess he must have a little
bit
um uhoh am I supposed to cut away no
okay
don't we need to see
this I guess this isn't spoiler
necessarily I mean we've seen this dude
before
yeah who's
there who comes to my
castle it' be awesome if he sounded like
who's
there that's his real voice hey who's at
my castle all
right find yourself a barrel at works
trust me save the game that's a good
call that's the best advice I have ever
heard wait now I'm stuck
here can't you can load other saves
right you can load your other a only one
hard save yeah but you can load your
auto saves look the other one's right
where
you hey what do you think of this save
should
we this looks like a good save load up
oh man I'm just looking at the last two
they look very similar um on the
mountain so you
know uh yeah this pillar is hot on my
feet o that would hurt so much look at
this oh yeah my name's link I'm here for
get
Zelda dude how the hell am I supposed to
do this I don't know well I could get
good you definitely got a paraglider a
bit but they got flying Guardians soon
now so the problem and paraglide down
there okay so if you went that way right
that's a that's a fast moving stream
there Eric we got
it oh hey
guys move move your
ass
oh oh on wait I just I'm selling books I
thought you had your stealth rice my
name's
link oh no I have no stamina it's okay
just keep walking
emergency eat food
run N I would get to that plateau and
hope you can run up it I think you can
but there's another oh God there's a
flying one too to your left just so you
know whatever the game play stopped yes
it did it most certainly did I'll fix it
oh no oh you know what do the redock
redock it oh yeah yeah redock there's
one cool thing about the switch is I can
redock and everything would be right
back to where it
was bye-bye gameplay now it's coming
back oh we know oh we know we know it's
frozen we know it's frozen thanks
Ryan oh I'm looking at the chat baby we
appreciate it yeah yeah we're good you
got to remember there's delay where did
we last leave uh you were running up the
hill so they missed all that Guardian
[__] but that's fine okay so previously
on
link
previously on link tries to go get
Cannon I jumped off here uh had no
stamina so I ate some hot steak yep and
it gave me a boost that got me here what
the hell is
that I don't know like a turret yeah it
is a turret there so there's one right
in front of you and there's definitely
oh rats turn around oh follow the stream
maybe hell no why
not dude you're going to run out of
stamina that's for sure you know what
why don't you just reload your save then
it's like nobody missed
anything oh God don't show him
that no that's just a castle I don't
know that's the same spot though where
you were running off the thing right all
right fine right okay fine
previously previously on uh prefrozen
gameplay this is this is basically where
we are were except you were hearing Rob
probably scream a little bit because a
fly flying Guardian was chasing him okay
squealing something sure uh yeah it was
it was pretty heated so I guess let's
repeat that yeah and hopefully I can
pull off that all right here we go hi my
name's link I'm tr get above you must
not see you though no that's the camera
oh okay you got that sneaky you got the
sneaky rice hi my name's link I'm trying
to get
Zelda hell yes Tay reset oh yeah that's
right it's like nothing ever happened
that's why we have saves
baby I have a feeling what's the feeling
I don't know I don't know I have a
feeling that this is going to go perfect
all should I go for it yeah nail it I
don't know man
fora give him enough stamina to climb
the hill I got some in reserve bit oh
yeah cuz you could eat although that's
weird because like you'd be eating while
you're climbing so EA one handed hot
look how hot this is both both
figuratively and literally hot he's
sweating hot bod on a hot
rock Ganon clamity hot I'll shut up here
we go when you're about to say a bad
word just say sugar instead uh we'll try
Kings tellington that's kind of
hard hello boys it's me
link
ooh oh yeah we sneaking baby we sneaking
yeah perfect in there we did it we in
there it's all downhill from
here I'm ready maybe you'll get
something good oh yeah Wildberry my
favorite oh durian have you ever smelled
durian no I have not I actually don't
even know that is real stink is it it
doesn't taste like what it smells like
but it's got some real real terrible
smell to
it oo look at Eric what was it I missed
it I got we got some hot Arrow
ooh that's a nice Arrow I got fire
arrows too say it's pretty cool huh I I
love it I love that I'm really normally
the guy that hates puns I love it when
you talk like that here we
go what's
this
another
walkway this is so this is so funny it's
just like like wakes up he's like I got
to go get Zelda doesn't do anything else
doesn't even wear clothes Zelda
ah oh uh-oh oh God okay oh there's
another
one so is that one just on the thing
you're on he's on he's on patrol so
let's think
here I
mean d yeah as headphone Mage says we're
doing pretty good Duran smells like feet
and onions but taste amazing I've never
tasted it but I've
definitely uh had a durian in a fridge
before and that thing was awful uhoh
naked link is baay says risky fitra I AG
B I agree you think you can kill that
thing should I no no no no no I'm on a m
dude stealth link turned on holly wolf
saying I'm literally playing and
watching L making all that money selling
my cooked food that's a lot of Zelda
thanks Holly thanks I'm not high he's
high off life I'm high off this altitude
you you know what it is it's the it's
the Calamity that's that's flying around
all that yeah yeah yeah yeah that makes
sense all right this guy's totally going
to see me but I'll blend in and pretend
I'm a CH yeah yeah yeah yeah does he
come over here who knows he's going to
make a patrol right I'm good he is this
Hyrule Castle yes yes this is the
castle you can what an idiot all right
can you make that you can get close
enough probably right that looks like a
hard thing to climb let's see if I can
get a little higher huh no that's good
enough nailed it no problem three hearts
no problem oh Eric we're I oh this is
insane oh oh look at that guy that guy
is is strong I'll tell you that yeah
he's strong oh what about his brother
his brother stronger cuz he's got that
hot scarf on I see uh what's up what
were you going to say before you saw it
you got distracted by our uh enemies
there I don't oh I I've never G I've
never done this obviously oh well you
know what what front door
open did I eat did I eat those sneaky
rice balls yeah you did unless you
didn't eat it this time around oh no
it's still there go back no oh you did
eat it damn damn
sugar and
water oh there's raw meat everywhere oh
that guy is gigantic he s look listen to
him snarl oh we got oh we got oh we got
a trio dude this is they're having a
feast though man damn looks good that's
mushrooms got some some raw meat maybe
some prime
meat oh yeah safe yeah yeah yeah gaming
gumper oh those guys are serious bad I
want to try something use the ruines
link what's up what are you going to try
hey
guys supper ready oh what are you what
the okay naked link is a Ninja really
what you don't understand is that
his that was he I'm surprised you're
half cool oh look at this chicken I'm
surprised you're not dead rawle bird
thanks for that bird
stupid what was your plan uh I didn't
have one okay that's the best kind of
plan
right don't mind us just running through
the castle mostly
naked we know what we're doing look at
this this is going so
well I don't have any
Flint shoot
oh I want to cook this
bird yeah yeah yeah yeah oh no way I did
I should have dropped the wood
first whoops no that's wrong that's
wrong Rob the Boy Scout
here all right this is for you Zelda a
fire just don't burn yourself and kill
yourself okay yeah I don't know if I
could have any less
Health uh dinner let's have some
what you with with some peppers uh n uh
a little bit of mushroom and um this is
going to be a skewer I can already tell
how did he live that's a good question
Tyler and Josh I have no idea how we're
this far andeh you know was we all know
the answer to this I think it's because
you jumped and you probably didn't take
full like a full hit or something right
although you have no armor yeah I got
kind of grazed that spear he had looked
real awesome wait I thought you just
cooked that bird I
did oh I thought I did the the the
shroom was ready before the bird yeah
you know chicken takes a while to cook
man you're absolutely right don't want
to get that
salmonella put your clothes on nah we
good n nah we look better like this
don't wa
link this is going really well uh Eric
yeah it's 12 I know but we're you
haven't died yet and I feel like you can
get
farther oh yeah roast that's a nice I
don't even have that many hearts that's
fine dude I have so much cooked food now
even in my playthrough that I don't have
that many hearts all right just speedrun
we're just going to run how about just
book it you're right I'm wasting time
let's just book should I put out the
fire no okay yeah you're right you might
have to come back to that later you
might need it dead end damn no it's not
my name's link I know what rocks are
oops oh apparently the other one was one
too I know what I'm doing oh uh I know
that guy yeah you know him yeah he's a
he's an ex-f friend of mine okay cool
don't go say hi then he's sleeping I
think
oh no don't get
distracted suck
it oh I got to go back
oo 48 damage though you know what I
shouldn't have done Eric woken that guy
up that's right where is the sword oh I
got to drop you got to drop something
uhoh oh why' you wake him up you got to
do it in inventory okay that works maybe
with that sword you can kill let's go
[__] nope you're not killing him you
are so no I got him let's go
what okay I think Rob purposely did that
no I did I did not I did not no I did
not I want to play Forever all right all
right well we got to go though uh okay
thank you guys so much for tuning in I
appreciate everyone in YouTube twitch
checking us out if you guys like I said
earlier haven't followed us you
definitely should because Rob and Peter
who's unfortunately not here that I'm
subbing in for uh are going to start
doing a Zelda weekly live stream where
they do a bunch of cool different like
things uh try out physics stuff you know
snowboarding just anything you can think
of also they're looking for things you
might you guys might want to see so
definitely follow them on Twitter at
Robert Handlery and PC Brown um but yeah
Rob uh why don't you you know give a
little sure yeah it's going to be really
fun I'm uh I'm super excited to uh have
the stream I think this game is so
awesome and vast and big and spectac
that uh there's enough to do a weekly
show by far uh so yeah uh tweet me at uh
yeah again Robert Handlery uh and any
ideas anything like that and we'll kind
of set up a show every week where we
tackle them limitations you know only
play with uh a Duke uh deu stick that
can happen uh tie balloons to bombs and
exploit that we'll do it a lot of fun
stuff uh Thursdays 10:30 a.m. I believe
Pacific 10:30 Pacific all right uh thank
you guys so much and thank you everyone
um Zelda fan love you too maybe uh yeah
thanks Eric for filling in man you
killed it on the chat there no worries
thank you guys so much see you guys
later